عندما يحل الظلام
قبل الفجر في منطقة كابادوكيا التركية ،
يكون الفارس المتضائل معنا جميعًا
مع سيمفونية على عكس أي سمفونية لم أسمعها من
قبل جوقة من الانفجارات الإيقاعية من الشعلات
تليها بالونات رقص الرقص
تتجه عالياً معلنةً باليوم الجديد
لقد وصل
إلهي ، وقد أنجزت الشعلات عملها
الآن ، استولت آلهة الرياح
على زمام الأمور ونأخذنا إلى السماء ، واستعاد الهدوء ،
إنه حقًا شيء رائع أن نرى كل
هذا
يتحرك بسرعة الريح
[موسيقى]
السلام والهدوء عندما  ترى الكثير من
المدربين السياحيين الذين تعتقد أنهم
لا ، ولكن هنا جميع السياح الآخرين
يطيرون بالونات ويضيفون إلى تجربتي
المذهلة
وتحت السبب في أننا نقوم
بتضخيم منظر طبيعي يبدو غريبًا تقريبًا ،
اثنان مقابل صخور مقذوفة من
البراكين  منذ آلاف السنين ،
منحنا المداخن الخيالية التي
شكلتها الطبيعة ومنحتها
[موسيقى]
هذه هي الطريقة للوصول إلى كابادوكيا
كابادوكيا هي منطقة تاريخية
تقع في وسط تو  rkey
وموقع تراث عالمي
تابع لليونسكو ، المداخن الخيالية التي تجعل هذا المكان
مثل هذا الرسم
تأتي في جميع الأشكال والأحجام المخروطية منها
منها مدببة ، حتى أن بعض
الطبيعة الموحية قد أعطتنا
المداخن الخيالية والمناظر الطبيعية ،
لكن الحضارات القديمة هي التي تحولت
و  تكييفها مع غرضها الخاص
أنت